Speaker 1: There is an election in Georgia
tomorrow.
It's the special Senate runoff election to
determine will Democrats have a 5050 majority
needing Kamala Harris to be the tie breaking
vote?
Or will Democrats have a 5149 majority in
the Senate?
The races in Georgia between incumbent Democratic
Senator Raphael Warnock and challenging Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker, a former
president, Barack Obama.
You know the guy Obama?
That guy.
He was in Atlanta over the weekend campaigning
for Raphael Warnock.
You really have to see this.
Obama's really good at this.
Crushing Herschel Walker for his unintelligible
rants of late, including one in which he talked
about what was it, vampires and werewolves.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Every day he comes up with something.
Every day.
Unidentified: Since the last time I was here.
Since the last time I was here, Mr. Walker.
Speaker 2: Has been talking about issues that
are of great.
Speaker 1: Importance to the people of Georgia.
Right.
Unidentified: Like whether it's better to
be a vampire or a werewolf.
Speaker 1: Very true.
Speaker 2: This is a debate that I must confess
I once had myself.
When I was.
Speaker 1: Seven.
Then.
I grew up, right.
Speaker 2: In case you're wondering, by the
way, Mr. Walker decided he wanted to be a
werewolf, which is great.
As far as I'm concerned.
He can be anything he wants to be except for
United States.
Speaker 1: Right.
That's the critical part since the last.
Speaker 2: Time that since the last time I
was here, apparently he also claimed that
he used to let me beat him at basketball.
Unidentified: But then he admitted then we've.
Speaker 2: Never actually met.
Speaker 1: Right.
That's typical of war.
And I'm sorry.
Walker regularly telling stories that are
impossible.
Speaker 2: So I guess this was more of.
Unidentified: An imaginary weapon that I laid
on him.
Now, listen.
Speaker 2: This would be funny.
Unidentified: If he wasn't running for Senate.
Speaker 1: That's that's exactly the point.
And as I've said before, listen, it's all
fun and games, right?
Trump running for president in 2015, 2016.
If you had a Republican Party that was more
like the Democratic Party in which such an
obviously unqualified buffoon didn't have
a shot at the nomination, we could all laugh
at the entire Trump thing.
He never would have been the Republican nominee.
He never would have become the president of
the United States.
That's not the situation we have in the U.S.,
unfortunately, now.
Raphael Warnock also spoke.
I mean, it was a rally for him, after all.
And let's take a look at a little bit of that.
Speaker 2: If we're honest, I believe in my
soul that Georgia knows that Georgia is better
than Herschel Walker.
Let's hope.
Unidentified: Herschel Walker.
You.
Speaker 2: You deserve a senator who cares
enough about the people to actually know the
issues.
Speaker 1: Or at least an issue, if not the
Speaker 2: So the senator, who will tell you
the truth.
Unidentified: You deserve a senator who actually
lives in Georgia.
Speaker 1: Is that too much to ask?
And as we recently found out, of course, what
was suspected appears to be true.
Herschel Walker really lives in Texas and
that's where he declares homestead exemption.
And it's a whole other story in and of itself.
We're down to the last few hours.
If you live in Georgia, make sure to vote.
We'll have results tomorrow night